so this is what a lot of players will do
is they'll have an instinct of what the
first move will be and they'll play it
without perhaps seeing the full
variation and that can be that's
sometimes the main reason why problems
are solved incorrectly today we're going
to do
Lito Scotland puzzles it's very similar
to chess a compact trainer where we get
a rating and the goal today will be to
get as many problems correct as possible
and to get the highest rating as
possible and we'll all work together
well we'll go through it's gonna give a
variety of problems I think the more we
solve the harder it will get so it will
probably start out relatively easy but
then hopefully towards the end it will
become a lot more difficult this one's
white to move guard you see it yep okay
yes Queen Queen a six
I think Queenie six is is very simple
simply double attacking the king and the
bishop now one piece of advice when
you're doing these puzzles there's no
time limit and I I always try and
reinforce this with students is accuracy
is a lot more important than speed so
when you think you have the solution you
should try and visualize it see if
there's any defense I think this is very
simple we just we're gonna pick up the
bishop and go up material and we take
the bishop very nice
so we officially have a puzzle rating I
don't know if you guys can see this we
gained 260 points for solving that that
puzzle when we first start out we're
playing from this this new accounts the
first several puzzles if we get
correctly the rating will increase at a
much rap or much more rapid pace so it
could get more difficult relatively
quickly will continue okay so
Queen f7 white to move what to do
and for some of these I'll be thinking -
yep
rook f6 I think again very simple we
just kin the Queen and we're going up
material I like it take very nice
we'll continue wait to move
I think this one is deceivingly easy
what's the move
yeah like you might assume that the
bishop can't be taken because of the pin
but we can just take it with the Queen
and this this actually came from a game
most of these puzzles are generated
through games played on me chess and we
can see the the player playing black
here is rated just below 2000 and played
94 not realizing the bishop could be
taken so why does just going up up going
up a piece and very nice we'll continue
from here okay things are getting messy
white to move I'll have to be thinking
here too maybe it's still relatively
simple yeah yeah Knight take F to Knight
take F to rook take F to there's also a
bishop take e to this is a bit peculiar
so there's maybe two potential options
we should start by counting material
here because material wise um black is
up to pawns right well works are
currently equals so we could take the
the rook or Knight and seems like both
moves when materials you have a pot
and I take d3 right and there's 92
possibilities yeah well I think I think
after a bishop take e to Knight take T
three Black is doing fine with material
because white one white one the exchange
rook four Knights but because black has
what two pawns and some active pieces 92
is a threat white probably doesn't want
to go into that line and I think it's
much more effective for a white just to
take on f2 ah Knight d2 then we take the
rook so yeah I might take f2 we win more
material and we're simplifying is we're
we're still attacking the rook there's
going to be trades let's go ahead and do
this hopefully it's not incorrect
yeah we're just trading on f2 and in the
final position White's up a bishop for
for two pawns but the two bishop
advantages is really nice here for
whites
so we're four out of four we're up to
nineteen seventy four I'm sure the
puzzles are going to start getting more
difficult let's continue here pawn g6
this is actually a I think of a somewhat
common opening trap I see it right away
but anyone want to suggest a move yep
rayona yes
Queen a4 yeah so this is a nice kind of
just forcing combination where we trade
on before we check on a4 we double
attack the the night in the king and
when the knight moves back to c6 the
knight is pinned and we have the final
move pawn d5 and I'm pretty sure there's
just no way for bucks to get out of this
without losing losing a minor piece
let's go ahead and do that
take take Queen a4 and d5
now if the Queen we run let's say b5
black could sometimes get camera play
with a 6-2 attack the Queen but in this
case there's no good way for black to
attack the Queen after d5 and like d7 so
if we take the knight there's a knight
c5 and then we can just retreat the
Queen and we're still up a piece yeah
okay so far so good
continue training congratulations we
broke mm I think the next step is to to
break 2100 and there's less fluctuation
the more problems we solve so you
already have an idea okay rook e to
yeah so this position it's about it's
actually about making multiple threats
rookie two has a the simple threat of
rook take b2 and also threatening Bishop
to f2 I was working I was working
earlier with the students and we were
talking about identifying targets in the
position I think positions like this
it's really important to identify
potential targets and especially in
White's position because a bishop is
undefended the rook is undefended the
King is somewhat exposed and sometimes
if you have trouble finding a tactic or
maybe not not seeing all the tactics in
your own games you want to identify
targets because that those are usually
clues which will lead you to to finding
the best move in this case rookie two
should just be winning material white
plays rook take out five now the
question is do we take the bishop or do
we take the rook just take the rook
probably yeah it's just more valuable
and black will be up to exchange very
nice okay we'll move on that's that was
problem number six so we're we're
continually gaining points black to move
in this position right off the bat and
realizing black is down three pawns
so tactics are necessary to find here
okay yeah rook e8 very simple move
threatening the back rank means the
problem with a move like rook e8 is
white could just defend against the
threats like white could probably play
g3 or h3 creating some escape square for
the King and I'm not sure how powerful
that would be of course a major theme in
this position is a potential for back
rank meet the fact that this rook is
tied down to defending mate
and it is a possible team in this
position but I wouldn't be entirely
confident with her key aides
so I think this is the first problem
where most people are a bit stumped I
think I'll go ahead and try and explain
my thought process here unless you have
an idea a queen g3 is definitely a can
of move which came to mind the issue is
I don't think you have a threat here
even if I give you another move in a row
what would you play after Queen d3 yeah
of course here you have the idea right
so if Queen d3 why couldn't spend some
time to play h3 and the rook is defended
so I think I'll go ahead and try and
explain my thought process is in this
position we would like to distract the
rook but I I don't see anything that
effective so I think what we can do is
focus on a different target in the
position and a very important target to
identify as f2 pod and the fact that we
could we we have a candidate move here
rook b f8 which is a simple attack
against the pond if we can take the pawn
I think very good things will happen and
I'm not entirely sure if if White has
any good way to defend the pawn is this
what you were gonna say yeah so yeah
exactly
rook our fates if white plays f3 then we
can play your move Queen take G 2 then
the rook would be defending supporting
the Queen on G 2 so rook f8 we should
try and at least find some defense for
whites it looks like the only defense of
the pawn would be to play rook F 1 and
then we should probably keep calculating
is there a continuation after rook f8
rook f1 yeah
I think I'll go ahead and show where
we're gonna take the pawn on f2 so ro
cafe rook f1 and this is this event this
is about finding forcing moves in this
case we're going to continue with
forcing moves and just capture the pawn
and f2 with the Eirik because after okay
after rook take f2 blacks threatening
made on g2 again and if rook take f2 we
have we have Queen beat one which is a
really nice resource in the position
leading to this back remains so let's
play it out i'm relatively confident in
this so that after UI plays a different
move Queen d5 didn't see coming
it's attempting to defend the g2 pawn
but I assume we can just take and white
should be in trouble let's go for taking
haha
sometimes this will happen when you're
doing the puzzles you'll you'll be
confident and move and then it'll play
out a line that you don't expect and
then we have to keep thinking in this
case we would love to play rook g2 but
the Queen is defending against rook g2
so what would another candidate move be
in this position you know what I'm
actually realizing I think we can still
favorite g2 because if let's calculate a
bit deeper Queen takes you to Rick take
g2 King take g2 we have Queen c2 check
double attack and if the King runs to f1
or h1 we're gonna keep checking and
taking pawns this is a common mistake
which some people fall into when it
comes to solving these tactical
exercises which I almost made myself
where I considered rook g2 and I
rejected it too early a very common
mistake even in in tournament play where
if you were rejected moved too early
without digging deeper sometimes you'll
miss opportunities in this case rook g2
we don't want to reject too early we dig
deeper and yeah we have this really nice
Queen c2 move
and the resulting endgame is just
winning for black mrs. Rooke okay that
was probably the toughest one so far any
questions about that
just to recap rookie fates not the
easiest first move to consider but other
key line was after f1 the idea was to
take take and queen be one with with
force mates any questions let's move on
okay we have seven down or about 20
minutes in and we broke 2,100
congratulations
so I will say I do puzzles occasionally
from my own account on me chess and my
puzzle rating is I think just over 2,300
so I think but one of the goals should
be to pass 2,300 so on the way perfect
so far black to move weird position
I think the major question here is can
we just simply take the bishop and
sometimes this will happen in in these
puzzles is where the the best move could
be obvious but sometimes there's tricks
and this it's up to us to make the
decision how many people would like to
take the bishop how many people have
this is like their first impression I
mean I would fit in that in that group
most certainly just take the bishop I
don't see how white is getting
counterplay and this is very much like a
game situation where sometimes you can
take a free piece but before you take
the piece you have to ask yourself does
the opponent have any counter play in
this case if we take the only counter
play I see is pawn takes pawn and then
we might just like to play King h8 e six
so take take and then there's a trick
here where if we take the pawn there'd
be discover check so I think the King h8
would keep the King safe and I think
black is doing very well there I mean
Black is up up a bishop and the knight
is about to come to e5 which is such a
strong piece in terms of attacking and
defending so let's go ahead and yeah
this is probably the the key moment
where it might seem attractive just to
take the pawn back but this is very
common in chess where we don't take the
pawn and we play King h8 to leave the
pawn sheltering the black King in this
case there's no follow up for whites 95
is coming make sense to everyone okay
let's continue gained another 22 points
there ooh
on g6 I see the move right away this is
a classic pattern leave it up to you
guys
I think I see the move right away
sometimes you can't get too too cocky
yeah
Queen D for this is another one of these
cases where you just want to identify
the targets undefended pieces on d6 yeah
and sometimes like you'll identify
multiple targets everything highlighted
in red is a potential target even the
king and sometimes it's just a matter of
a figure out the right tactics or the
right targets to exploit with tactics in
this case Queen d4 I think is very
simple I saw this right away than I
realized Bishop take a3 could be a move
but then we can take the rook and we're
just winning material and it should be
right and we take the rook I don't think
there's any counter play for a block and
after we take the rook we're threatening
Bishop h6 as well as just taking the
bishop okay very nice we'll continue
rook b7 interesting you see it right
away
I yeah there's a move that's screaming
to be played and then I think it's a
matter of calculating yeah rook take g2
King take G 2 and then Bishop d5 yeah as
very important we play Bishop d5 first
and we don't trade the rooks first right
so take take we don't want to trade the
rooks because this endgame could be a
bit unclear we're not actually going up
material but if we take on g2 and then
play Bishop d5 first black is just Appa
Appa bishop for a call so Rick take G 2
this is classic this is a target this is
a target wide open position 55 screaming
to be played and of course we should
take with the bishop and not the rook
and take the Knights okay
so that was satisfying gaining more
points perfect so far and I will say
it's better to remain perfect than to
get through more problems quickly I
think I already made that point but when
you do these on your own it's okay to
spend maybe like five ten twenty minutes
if you're stuck on the problem then to
chose just try and guess because that's
how you get the most amount of value
from it's okay some end game problem
whites and move I think it's just a
simple tactic do you see it yeah rook f7
double attack I don't think there's
anything stronger let's go for that now
this is actually an interesting scenario
where if we take the bishop how many
people would just take the bishop or
that that would be your first instincts
that would be my first instinct but you
would play off three we have to realize
that if we take the bishop right away
and then king take g5 it could be a
really hard and game to win because we
have one pawn left and if it gets traded
off rook and Knight versus rook is
usually just a draw yeah so I think yeah
I think Knight f6 is very strong move to
keep the initiative defend the pawn and
then then we'll probably take the bishop
the next move and then we'll have the
very strong passage upon does that make
sense to everyone I have six kind of in
importance in between move don't take
the bishop right away who the King moves
there now I think it's time to take the
bishop and the D pawn the D pawn will
allow way to win much more easily any
questions about that let's move on we
can vote that this is another feature in
the chess where it's very it's very kind
of what's the right word like the the
problems are generated in terms of the
computer basically picks problems where
it thinks tactics exist
and then it has a vote
system where if you upload problems and
more users will be likely to to do the
same problems okay continue
okay ninety-five we're on the verge of
breaking 2200 we're 21 97 so let's not
mess up here not to move
I already have an idea yeah
rook c2 is definitely an idea that's
screaming to be played because the
bishops undefended the Queen is a target
now I'm wondering because we have a few
options here we could play rook c2
immediately or we could take on e5 first
and then Roxy too so it's a question
what's what's the best execution I think
we the idea is pretty clear but how do
we execute let's imagine rook seats you
right away is there any problem with
that
what you're saying okay if if Knight
takes first take rook see - yeah I think
Queen take b6 this could be the problem
with taking the knight first there would
be the threat of rook da mates and there
would be no time to take the bishop
button on me - but if we play rook c2
first we avoid that line we keep b6
defended but I'm imagining like if we
play rook see - there's Queen b3 and
that seven is the targets Bishop d5 but
then we lose the rook
so this is where it starts to get
trickier where you have to be aware of
what the point wants to do and the
harder problems are positions where if
you don't realize what the poet wants to
do you can run into trouble so rook C -
Queen b3 I think there might be a simple
approach in that position I think you
said Queen d5 if we play Queen d5 we
trade Queen or I could trade Queens and
then save the bishop so rook C - Queen
b3 I think then we can just take the
Knights in the sense we're defending f7
and keeping that the initiative and
after white takes back then we take on e
2 and then we're up a piece Y could
damage the pawn structure but we're
still at the piece I think black is much
better there so let's go for that
hopefully we're not missing anything
defend f7 my taking the Knights and then
take you who the line keeps going white
spreading this checkmate on g8
how to defend 95 looks very attractive
I like 95 there's also a bishop defy
well the problem is Bishop c6 doesn't
defending as 58 mates at rook t8 winning
the Queen I think it's a debate between
Bishop d5 and 95 I think a problem with
Bishop d5 is why can take twice on f6 95
we attack the Queen
so we attack and we block the rook from
targeting t8 I like 95 on the go for it
Queen be it that's a good sign we're
just trading Queens and success so that
was a little bit tricky like White had
maybe a bit more attack then expected I
want to go back there just to show one
line that maybe we didn't identify as
clearly but if we if we took the knight
first this was something we had to see
ahead of time where black could take on
b6 and then we have no time to take the
bishop because of Ivor of das so let's
keep going we we gained a lot of points
for that problem we're over 2200 yep Oh
95 95 attacking the Queen the bishops
attacks so one of the issues here is
that the computer is automatically
turned on
I accidentally glanced at the move
there's one winning move for a white in
this position and maybe I don't know how
the video is gonna be added at it but
yeah Queen take a sixes move I was going
to say viewers at home can pause the
video but I guess it's too late Queen
take a 6 is saving the Queen and the
bishop okay let's continue
weird position sometimes before you
start looking for a move in the position
you should just make observations like
try and evaluate what's going on in this
case White's last move taking the pawn
does leave the bishop attacked twice but
now the knight is attacked and I'm
counting material white just one upon
here so it's a situation black is down
material the Knights attacked what to do
but if yeah so situations like this
where you're nice attacked in the bishop
is attacked you want to look for night
moves you wanna maybe get the most up
for your nights and then later take the
bishop but Knight c3 just Bishop takes
c3 rights doesn't mean so much
AHA so if we take on e5 and then they
take c3 I think this is just a trade
though because Queen takes c3 you could
take the rook but black is not winning
any material and Queens could get traded
I'm pretty sure I see the solution and
I'll try and again talk through my
thought process in the situation like
this it's really important to just
consider the candidate moves and the
forcing lines which could lead to
something in your favor in this case oK
we've identified some cameras and I take
C 3 we rejected this is a candidate move
and this is a candidate move do you have
an idea yeah okay and sometimes you in
addition to looking for candidate moves
you also want to look for potential
ideas look for moves that maybe don't
work in this current position but might
work in the future
so potential ideas that I spot are
something maybe like rook g8 or maybe
some day moving the knight to be 4f for
its attack the Queen and sometimes when
you build up an arsenal of both the
candidate moves and the potential ideas
in a position you can start combining
them to work towards finding a solution
in this case what I one of the
approaches I used was I just calculated
rook takes e5 rook take II five and then
I identified a relatively forcing move
for black which is not recapturing the
rook but playing this move that I kind
of wanted to play earlier was 9 f4 and I
think this is winning material I think
after rook taking five rook taking five
nine at four we attack the Queen and
we're ready to recapture on e5
capture the rook on e5 and defend an eye
on f4 and I don't think there's any
counter play for a white two to deal
with that I think black is just going up
up a knight I agreed let's go for it ooh
forgot about this I think it's simple
though I think we just take the the rook
and there's no there's no way for white
to win back material we don't take the
Queen though if we take the Queen white
takes our Queen and then we're not
winning anything it just traits so we
take the rook okay sorry okay yeah
perfect so far more rating points gains
Queen c2 black to move and again I
encourage people to make observations
before looking for moves
equal material that's Knights of targets
I think a major theme in this problem is
taking advantage of this night in some
way yep queen g4 is a definitely a
candidate move g3 g5 so when I first
look at this position there's there's a
few moves that jump out Queen g4 g5 + e
4 these are all probably the most
aggressive moves to attack something but
it's a matter of making something work -
to win material so this is what a lot of
players will do is they'll have an
instinct of what the first move will be
and they'll play it without perhaps
seeing the full variation and that can
be that's sometimes the main reason why
problems are solved incorrectly I have a
feeling queen g4 is not the first move
simply because after Queen g4 g3 the
knight has a safe haven on g2 and we
don't want to give white time to play g3
so I don't think we're trapping or
winning anything after Queen 84 I think
there's a more effective approach here
which combines some of the resources
yeah
queen g4 this would be a nice double
attack this this line would be winning
material yeah very nice
but what if efore Bishop you to know
queen g4 there then we play g5 so it was
actually just a matter of combining all
the the three different moves in the
right order
efore i think is is winning material
here because we we take away the only
safe square for the night we don't give
white any time to play g3 and yeah
Bishop to g5 would chop the Knights
let's go for it always feels good
playing that final move okay we are on
the verge of breaking 2300 and problems
might be getting tougher this one looks
really easy though whites a move what
would you play yeah do a queen h6 what
would you play Queen takes c5 actually
both moves look attractive I think we
take c5 it's just a free bishop if you
want to play Queen h6 you have to
calculate your threatening mates but
Bishop take d4 and blacks alive but it's
just I think it's just a free bishop
well of course in chess if you had the
situation if you see the free bishop you
would like to look for more maybe you
would calculate Queen h6 it doesn't lead
to anything so we take the bishop and we
take okay no what happened with the
sound there yeah that was relatively
easy I don't know so what's interesting
about this this tool is every puzzle has
its own rating based on who solves it
correctly and who solves it incorrectly
so the puzzle rating for this one is
1981 which I think a lot of people who
tried to solve this probably played
Queen h6 not realizing the bishop is
hanging so that's maybe why this this
has a high rating shall I turn it off
tonight huh
Queen eighty-six well so we should we
should always make our own conclusions
before checking the stock fish so oh if
Queen h6 Bishop take d4 I would guess
that it's relatively equal black might
even be better there because there's a
weak pawn on d4 oh you can take with
rook yeah that's probably about equal
equal material
let's check bishops 84 rook take t4
slightly I don't know why it sings
slightly better for black maybe because
the White King is a bit more exposed
sometimes you can't always trust
evaluations either or if it's giving
right if it's giving like minus 0.1 or
minus 0.3 sometimes it's something very
miniscule that you have to have to
understand what the computer is looking
at but okay black does have some
initiative here against the hu pawn oh
yeah let's continue continue interesting
position white is up to pawns but
there's a rook hanging on d1 but do we
take it you have an idea yeah
yes I think this is a whole decision
like it's clear at some point we want to
take the rook but what would the
difference be is h3 we're forcing king
h2 and then if we take the rook then we
actually have to ask ourselves what is
white doing to get counterplay because
rook g5 looks scary and might not be so
simple so this might actually require
calculation where we have to we have to
keep in mind this h3 move and calculated
position with h3 and without h3 I don't
think there's any other major candidate
moves to consider here apart from h3 and
Queen take t1
if we take the pawn then rooked 86 and
then if we take the Queen would take
back so since white has two defenders on
the pond you can't take it right away
because you only have two attackers so
this is a hard situation sometimes to be
in in like in your own game where you
can take material but it's unclear like
you have to really think from your
opponents perspective and here the whole
question is can white does white have a
strong continuation yeah
King f6
I see what you mean
so just to demonstrate the line oh you
said h3 first King h2 here and after
rook g5 King x6 that's very possible so
I'm I'm thinking that if we go for a
similar variation like if we take the
rook right away and then rook g5 he got
six white would have the option of
taking on h4
so after h3 king h2 Queen's 81 rook g5
you're saying King f6 or we're
threatening the rook were threatening
King take g5 and well white probably
can't play f4 because of something like
Queen d2 and then the King gets in
trouble so I like the the spirit of
keeping are you trying to agree gain the
initiative after rook g5 but what if
what if the Queen somehow defends like
Queen c5 and now there's some threat of
Queen f5 or Queenie five mate looks a
bit scary
Queens 86 as possible okay let's start
from scratch so h3 king h2 queens 81
rook g5 King f6 Queen c5 and then you
said Queen take d6 and now White has
perhaps a few checks let's say Queen at
five check you would play King isse Evan
queenie for check queenie six and then
there's rookie five so you would play
King f8 and this is after Queen e4 and
yeah it looks like white runs out of
checks still looks a bit shaky but maybe
there is rook h5 in that position and
then there's a threat of some rogue H a
check Brooks where it works on d8 but
the Kings on f8 does everyone follow
that that's a hard line to follow let's
let's repeat one more time h3 and this
is sometimes where visualization is is a
really key skill to have where it's
really important to keep track of where
all the pieces are so you're seeing the
position clearly even if it's several
moves ahead
so h3 King h2 Queen take t1 rook g5 oops
King f6
so queen h6 because there's no weight in
in what position so okay so you say the
line h3 King h2 mm-hmm rook g5 Oh King
age six mmm
still actually King age six might make a
lot of sense but maybe then f4 it's
sometimes hard in these situations
because there's there's so many
different ways of position can branch
out after a king h6 that's right
Oh after f4 yeah I like that and then
the King appears to be safe
did you want to say something yeah sure
ah Queen f3 but then there's Queen e5
mate yeah you defend f5v 5 is also a
major target
I actually liked the line we're going to
h6 where it just seems safer for the
king
so h3 King h2 Queens a d1 or if g5 King
h6 because we're still attacking the
rook we are blocking the H file but I
don't know if that's too important given
that word just up a rook we're
threatening g5 or threatening d6 Queen
c3 after king h6
okay so one more time we'll play I move
very soon because at some point we might
not be 100% confident but we'll give it
our best our best try I guess the
question is why don't we take the rook
immediately and go for the same line
probably because want a pawn right but
then we can still take on g6 so I'm
wondering if there's a different
resource for white my first instinct is
h3 but here here take rook here so
anything else other than rook g5
probably not
King h6
I think we should just go for it I will
say I'm not 100% confident sometimes
there's like hidden resources in these
tactics which are easy to overlook but
spending a lot of time on this let's go
for h3 we can always think if the
position changes unexpectedly oh so we
try again or yeah let's actually try
again given I'm I'm a bit baffled it's
probably queen take t1 or maybe is there
another move that six doesn't make much
sense sorry you said Queen take t1 but
then it's White's move
sorry what's the first move Queen take
do you one rook g5o we're keeping the
resource of h3 for later but I don't
know how that changes anything
oh you're saying Ritchie ate so Queens a
d1 which I think we can assume is the
move that's let's play it Queen take to
you one okay
Queen c3 well there's discovered check
possibilities this is maybe a resource
we missed in the other line where after
Queen c3 it might be important for some
reason to have our pawn on h4 rather
than h3 so ok so we have to identify the
threat we're up a rook the threat is
rook g5 and then the eventual Queen g7
and that it's a double check threat so
if we play a move like Queens 86 rook g5
is a double check and we're think it's
losing because there's a lot of lot of
follow-up for whites sorry rook can i
play with g5 oh but the the computer
played this automatically so we have to
figure out the best move for a black in
this position King f8 is a move so f6
still rook g5
and then we move the king sorry no I we
said f6 yeah king s6 I don't think so
so f6 is a Canada move I like I like I
like the nature of f6 we blocked the
diagonal but after rook g5 King to f7 I
think white is winning after Queen c4
King f8 and rook g8 mates
so you're saying King f8 here so and
then rook over cage 5 not possible oh
wow you know what after King f8 whites
and move maiden to rook e8 King f8 runs
into rookie a mate or rook e8 and then
Queen h8 mates so I think okay just to
identify the mistake that we made was
not seeing this resource of Queen c3
earlier and this is a bus line for black
it's just a question how does black
defend this position we're upper rook
lines with f6
I don't think okay we didn't consider
everything kingi eights there's ripped
g5 King g6 we have not considered king
g6 Jets
if yeah but if King g6 does white have a
continuation it still looks scary but
there's no Queen chucks I'm just fearing
there could be a quiet move like Queen
III sorry rook take d6 Queen or let's
say rook g5 but your kings on g6 so we
said okay so the line is King g6 Queen
e3 you said rook take g6
and then ripped g5 if route 86
immediately there's double check we're
almost this is almost our our time limit
so we it might be most time effective to
just see the solution King g6 you want
to play I think this gives us the best
hope I yeah if this were a game in my
time is ticking I'd like one minute left
I would play King g6 because then if
white plays Queen e3 there should be
some defenses maybe f6 there but I'm not
entirely sure let's try King g6 and then
we'll try and understand the solution at
least King g6 wow it works now f6 or
maybe even Queen g4
I'm still baffled of why we want our
pong on on h4 rather than including h3
then Queen take g3 that might be the
reason if we have our pawn on h3 and we
played queen g4 f3 could just be a
really strong move for white and maybe
that's why we had to keep our pawn on h4
let's let's play Queen g4 and there we
go that was really difficult that was
like a that was beyond my level that's
probably uh-oh the polar rating is 23:39
yeah well I wonder if like maybe some
people have a 50/50 chance of getting
this this is a game of tweets between
two 1900s
and they just stumbled into like a
really complex line just to demonstrate
the line where if Queen or if h3 first
how do we go back wait a minute
Oh in this position if h3 first King
here Queen take t1
I think the first mistake initially was
neglecting to consider one of White's
strongest resources Queen c3 it's a hard
move to tie down fi especially when
you're black and you're searching for
resources for your opponent's sometimes
you'll be inclined not to search hard
enough but yeah Queen c3 because there's
so many like these mating ideas like
King f8 rookie is such a nice resource
for whites and if the same line happened
where King g6 queen g4 or sorry uh King
g6 Queen III Queen g4 I think this is
the one nuance f3 I'll check with the
computer yeah I think white in white
should be much better here given the
Queen is driven away from defending g5
yeah well stockfish loves white if we go
back or if take d6 could be drawn guess
that's the other thing in some of these
lines there's perpetual for whites like
rook take d6 white is getting enough
counter to enough counter play to draw
but I'm pretty sure though that winning
line was the only way to win to take the
rook first and leave the pawn on h4 this
a lot of this can be hard to calculate
now okay now there's there's a pretty
clear perpetual that was difficult but
that's one of the reasons I enjoy doing
this as some of these problems are
really tough and if we compare this to
weightlifting it's like lifting really
heavy weights and they're tough and you
might not be able to lift them at first
but that's how you get stronger and the
more you do even if you fail or solve
incorrectly like a lot if you go back
and try and realize the nuances and try
and take away themes that's that's how
you become a better tactician that's
what will ultimately improve your game
so I think we'll end it there sad to end
it on a failed tactic but I encourage
everyone to to do this on your own and
and try and try and be accurate and take
your time and dig deep
[Music]
you